epigenetics
i did an online course learning about it
when i was in university and went wow
this is cool i then read a book on it
i then met the author of the book a few
years later
and a few years later i'm now doing my
phd project which has involved you
guessed it looking at some epigenetic
marks
you might say i'm a fan which would be
true which is also why we are back with
an update on epigenetic marks
in particular epigenetic marks that are
being characterized to understand aging
now while there are many epigenetic
marks the ones that have been
characterized and been shown to have
changes that correlate with age are dna
methylation marks these marks influence
what genes are expressed within a cell
and have been used to create epigenetic
clogs
clogs like can predicts age based on
what subset of sites have the presence
of dna methylation
dna methylation is of interest because
it can be binary and it's information
rich you either have methylation or you
don't
but there is also still much we don't
understand about it
which is why i was intrigued to read
this recent review on dna methylation
and thought it would be worthwhile to
speak with carsten
a phd student at the institute for
health and sport at victoria university
in australia
who wrote this review as an extension
from our own research project
a better explanation of the epigenome so
um if we just break the word apart
if he is kind of
greek for on top or above and genome
would of course be our genetic code or
dna sequence
and so the epigenome is is um kind of
determines the operations of the cells
so these collection of chemical
modifications that sit above the genetic
code and they dictate
um the operations of the cells they
dictate if a cell is a neuron or if the
cells the skin cell and then they also
determine um the activity of that cell
you know how it responds to different
environmental um stimulation or space
for example
um and we are interested in a particular
epigenetic modification called dna
methylation and dna methylation is um
it's essentially just these little tags
or methyl groups that sit at very
precise location in the genome um and if
that site has a methyl tag we would say
it's methylated and if it doesn't have
that methyl tag with it and methylate it
and these are just really attractive to
us because they're very easy to quantify
so some marks change of age but it is
not that they all increase in
methylation of age or they all decrease
some go up some go down and then there
are some sites that get more variable
with age
kerstin is using new terminology to
overcome this
differentially methylated positions
would be our most well-described um
dna methylation changes that we see with
age and so
when we're talking about differentially
methylated positions in variably
methylated positions i'm just going to
say dnps and bmps and we're talking
about individual cpg sites that change
with age
so dmps are cpg stats that change in the
average methylation fraction
so
a site can gain methylation or it can
lose methylation with age and we measure
this average change over time
and why these are interesting is because
they they very closely track
chronological age or chronological time
so
young individuals of the same age will
share a methylation fraction
um say for example a methylation
fraction of 20 percent and then at older
ages at this same
dmp
older individuals might have an in a
methylation fraction of 80 so we would
say that that is obviously an average
change from between 20 to 80 percent
um
then conversely vmps are just a little
bit more um
they're less well characterized so
there's one major study that really
looked at them in in blood and um vmps
don't necessarily shift in their mean
methylation although some do but they
don't necessarily shift any methylation
but rather we look at their variability
over time so um
a lot of these sites we see this
increase in invariance in in methylation
fractions so
young individuals might have
the same methylation fraction but then
at older ages
people of the same age can have numerous
different methylation fractions at this
particular cpg site so we'll see this
really this divergence from from the
average okay yeah because i think that
leads on to my next question which is
you mentioned in the review how you
considered these or maybe these dmps
being more reflective of primary
mechanisms of aging whilst vmps may be
more reflective of secondary like um
more stochastic aging as you as you say
so could you maybe elaborate on that a
bit more
yes absolutely so um
aging has been defined in the past is
like these two processes happening so
primary aging being you know very
related to our maximum lifespan so we
see changes
you know
like the functional the function of our
cells and tissues kind of become
impaired with chronological aging with
chronological time you know we all
experience skin aging or lose muscle
mass and that would be you know primary
aging um and because dmp is very
closely uh track chronological aging and
we can you know use these sites to
predict chronological age we you know
these
we hypothesize are underpinning this
primary aging process and then
conversely secondary aging would be
you know those additional deleterious
changes that kind of increase our risk
for for disease and disability so
what i mean by that is we're all exposed
to different environmental um factors
over our lifetimes so
you know i could smoke be sedentary um
and you know experience a greater
functional decline than somebody else
who is of a similar chronological age
and that is what we would refer to as
secondary aging and so because vmps show
this divergence um from the average um
you know this this stochasticity as we
would say um we
we hypothesize that these are
underpinning or these are capturing some
some aspects of secondary aging and why
that's exciting is because if that is
the case that would mean that these
particular sites are um amenable to
intervention so these are the sites that
we can potentially act upon um
with you know drugs or lifestyle or
whatever the case may be
and so given the data that's been
collected it seems that the epigenome
gets more disordered the entropy
increases with age
so
entropy is quite an interesting concept
because
um
we're talking about um
the methyl i'm just going to focus
specifically on the methylome if we look
at
the dmps so these average shifts to
methylation we see that
many of these differentially methylated
positions
shift from
high methylation or low methylation in
young people to kind of like an
intermediate methylation of around 50
and so
what this is referred to as kind of like
the smoothing of the epigenetic
landscape which is what um davidson
speaks about you know like noise that's
kind of accumulating because
um
these
basically entropy is
a probability formula that we use to try
and
quantify all these age-related changes
in a single measure
so it's almost like a measure of of
uncertainty so if these sites are
shifting so methylation of around 15 it
becomes very difficult to predict the
methylation fraction at that particular
site um and that is
that is an entropic measure so we would
see this increase in entropic decay
with age and that's
the accumulation of noise in the ap
genome which is related to davidson k's
informational theory of age 2. oh cool
and so we've now spoken a lot about your
few but maybe we can now shift more to
like maybe the motivation behind your
review and maybe if you could elaborate
on your actual phd project and how that
relates to epigenetics
yes absolutely so um
my current project is um
we're taking on the very ambitious task
of
trying to build this
map of aging um in in humans and sort of
a multi-tissue map of of the aging
methylome and
then and in order for us to do that we
need to we're you know collaborating
with research groups all over the world
to try and gather as much data as we can
um in humans epigenetic data so we're
gathering
we've got about 186 data sets of apg
data from 14 human tissues so what we're
really trying to do is characterize all
these changes um with age and we were
really you know fortunate to um to
collaborate with um steve horvath and
andrew tischendorf on the review who
gave us some really good ideas about
about um
how to quantify aging and so you know
we're hoping to capitalize on those
expertise in the future but yeah
essentially we want to build this this
map of aging and then um publish it as
an online tool and then you know with
that
you know it's almost like a
um
it'll be a resource for for research at
researchers or pharmaceutical companies
in the future so then potentially assess
the effect of of different lifestyle
pharmaceutical interventions on these
aging signatures in different tissues um
okay yeah and so we said i'll find that
you're um more of a computational
biologist so what exactly is it that
you're doing are you trying to develop
the algorithms or are you processing the
data
um so we're pre-processing everything um
yeah
so my my research is obviously very um
bioinformatics or computational um
one one tool that we're actually using
so what we're trying to do is um so we
download and pre-process all this dna
methylation data and then we run
you know a series of statistical tests
to identify these these sites or these
um aging signatures you know in every
single data set and then what we need to
do is we meta-analyze um this data and
the reason why we're using a
meta-analysis is because
in human studies um
it's very difficult to obtain
epigenetic data from tissues other than
like that or saliva because it's hard to
come by you know like
a data set of muscle samples or heart
samples and so sometimes these data sets
are too small and lack um you know we
don't have sufficient statistical power
to identify these these aging signatures
in tissues other than blood
um and so by by using a meta-analysis we
kind of try to overcome this limitation
that we see in human studies
okay and so you mentioned that actually
getting access to tissues is one sort of
limitation at the moment and
in terms of the progress in the field
but what other questions in the space of
like epigenetics and dna methylation um
do you still feel like uh um unaddressed
obviously one question that comes up a
lot is that we don't necessarily know if
the marks are causal to the aging
process or they're just some kind of
reflective
indication of it causal consequence um
yes absolutely i mean
you know will we ever really know you
know what
what's the cause is it is it damage is
it metabolism
um we're not quite we're not quite sure
so that is certainly um that is
certainly a question you know once we've
kind of identified these sites what do
they really mean you know where are they
where are they occurring in the genome
what is their function and functional
studies are really difficult to do in
i think with with dna methylation
because
sometimes
sites don't act in isolation and we're
you know perhaps not quite sure which
sites are are working together to
produce a functional consequence
um
so yeah i mean that that is an area to
address i think also looking at you know
cellular heterogeneity is a big thing
so we're looking at cold tissue but if
whether or not these changes are
occurring
in specific cell types is is an area of
interest i think there is some work
being done in that in that area
and then something else i think is um
we know surprisingly little about the
sex specific
epigenetic aging in in different tissues
you know so where the males and females
um diverge in their epigenetic patterns
um with age and i think this is
important when we're looking when we're
thinking about lifestyle intervention
you know do males and females adopt the
same strategies um
and
at what ages you know do we do adoptive
strategies so this is a focus of some of
the um some of the work in our group is
looking at this sex specific aging but
yeah that's quite interesting you know
males and females exhibit very discarded
aging rates where females tend to
outlive males sort of every single age
um
but you know greater proportion of their
life is spent in mobility so there's
obviously some robust feature of biology
that's at day here but we're just not
quite sure at the apg level um what does
that look like
um
yeah and then of course you know um
longevity interventions
um a lot of our knowledge comes from
model organisms
um
so you know we want to see more in
humans so we our lab is also looking at
um the effect of exercise
um
on these aging signatures in muscle so
that yeah that's also an area of
interest i think for future studies
so is there future potential for
epigenetic clocks
truthfully i
that's a that's a difficult question i
don't know if i know the answer
um i mean i suppose you know epigenetic
the ep epigenome is attractive as a
therapeutic target because it is
plastic or malleable
um so you know if we can
i can take a swab and say you know
biologically your epigenetic marks are
saying that you're five years older than
you are but
you know and then i can exercise and see
those changes over time
um well you know those those changes
slow
that would be marvelous um
i don't know if i don't know right now
um you know there are consumer products
available that are biological age
predictors um i think there's a lot of
work that we that we need to do in this
space um
but yeah
so it seems there is still potential but
it needs more researchers like carsten
so what does it take to be a phd student
i think
uh for me i just have this um and i'm
sure it's the same for you just this
insatiable appetite for
for pursuing knowledge and um
[Music]
and you know science is something that
is so challenging it challenges you and
it challenges you on every single level
and the learning curve never ends
um and it really does keep you humble
um i also
i love discussing ideas i love
collaborations um
so i love you know working with people
that are passionate about what they do
and i think
i am
quite a purpose-driven person so
i like to think that you know the work
that we're doing
that you know our research group is
doing the collective field is doing um
will have
a positive impact on
people in the future and so that's
if if that's something that is appealing
to you you know it's a
it's not easy
but i certainly i wouldn't yeah i'd
certainly worth it i wouldn't i wouldn't
trade it
so research is very much still on the
way in exploring how epigenetics change
with age
i think an important takeaway is that
besides just looking at what sites
increase or decrease in methylation of
age a higher order level approach
integrating the changes of multiple
sites should be considered
i think
a major take home
you know aging is a driver of most
chronic disease
but
and we know this
but what we don't know we still you know
the upstream causes of of aging are so
you know fairly misunderstood or poorly
understood
um
the
the changes that we see in in the
methanol you know epigenetic clocks are
a huge focus in the in the in the field
at the moment
but there are so many ways that we can
quantify aging using dna methylation
data and i think that's a really really
big focus so we want to we want you know
they take away to be like
maybe we need to look at the methylene
in its entirety and not
um
you know
so kind of quantify these global
signatures of aging and by looking at
different features so looking at um
differential methylation available
methylation
entropy and you know i haven't even
touched on correlation networks which
are also very very interesting um so
there's just there's a lot that we can
do
um by looking at dna methylation data i
mean would you like to elaborate on the
correlation that works
oh i don't know if that's um
yeah so correlation networks
um
[Music]
but essentially you know mini cpg sites
and they don't act in isolation and so
we can measure these py cur pairwise
correlations this is this is steve
horvath's work
and we can measure these poise
correlations and we can build modules
um that we can then associate with aging
and aging phenotypes i think what we
don't know yet which is which is would
be really interesting is whether you
know there are modules that um
are kind of
robust in in young individuals but then
these correlations sort of
break apart or become less
um
strong i don't know if that's the right
word but you know what i'm trying to say
so we have these these these aging
modules and young that sort of
um lose correlation so our dna
methylation sites that lose correlation
with age so i think that would be a
really interesting
um
interesting um the thing to analyze
but work is still being undertaken to
make sense of the dna methylome but it's
cool stuff and i look forward to
checking out carson's research
so with that i hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening